un nuevo actor entra en la carrera a la
casa blanca los incendios en la costa
oeste durante su visita a california a
donde llegó para evaluar la emergencia
provocada por los incendios forestales
el presidente de donald trump se
enfrentó a la comunidad científica por
el cambio climático para empezar a hacer
frío lo van a ver aguas ojalá la ciencia
estuviera de acuerdo con usted no creo
que la ciencia sepa en realidad
pero hay consenso científicos sobre que
el cambio climático está haciendo al
estado de california cada vez más seco y
caliente lo que provoca más incendios
cada década desde 1980 ha sido
sucesivamente más calidad que la década
anterior y es más a los 6 años más
cálidos registrados a núcleo en los
últimos seis años desde el 2014 varios
fenómenos extremos no como incendios
forestales olas de calor sequías están
vinculados al aumento de la temperatura
mundial por lo que el demócrata joe
biden aprovechó los comentarios de trump
para atacarlo
si le das a un pirómano climático cuatro
años más en la casa blanca porque
alguien se sorprendería si tienen uno a
eeuu en llamas le das a un negacionista
del clima cuatro años más en la casa
blanca porque alguien se sorprendería
cuando más de eeuu esté bajo el agua
necesitamos un presidente que respete
las ciencias que entienda que el daño el
cambio climático ya está aquí a menos
que tomemos medidas urgentes
esto será más catastrófico y es que
mientras el presidente ha derogado
varias regulaciones medioambientales y
retiro a eeuu del acuerdo de parís
bailén anunció un plan de 2 billones de
dólares para incentivar la inversión en
energías renovables y detener las
emisiones contaminantes de las empresas
estadounidenses para el 2035